make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this
is rob and normally we have these versus
videos strictly on patreon it's one of
the tiers that you guys can become a
part of so you can basically vote every
wednesday on which characters we're
gonna have face off against each other
or
on which teams we're gonna have face off
against each other and then we release
the video for that respective tier on
patreon for this video we're going to do
what we do occasionally which is to
release it publicly to give people an
idea of what kind of content we produce
that's exclusive to patreon and in this
video we're covering the century versus
superboy prime now in typical fashion
we'll cover the origins and powers of
each of these characters
and then we'll end the video by
declaring one of them to be our winner
now starting with the sentry
he was created by paul jenkins and
jaylee and first appeared in the century
number one in the year 2000. now
although the century is by no means the
only superman knockoff that marvel's
introduced over the years he's probably
the most well received and popular among
fans at least among some fans i've
noticed it's the vocal minority that
hate the century but it's usually 50
people sounding like 5 000
but the sentry is the alter ego of
robert reynolds a man who was given a
serum that imbued him with the power of
a million exploding sons and so robert
uses his power to become the century one
of the most famous superheroes in the
world
but when we're first introduced to him
he's actually a middle-aged and
overweight man with no memory of his
past
career as a superhero eventually his
memories begin to return
and we learn that the sentry had a dark
counterpart hidden within a psyche known
as the void
knowing the danger the void posed the
sentry actually used a device atop
avengers watchtower to cause everyone
including himself to forget that either
the sentry or the void ever existed
thinking that doing so would prevent the
void from re-emerging spoiler alert
it didn't but because century is heavily
inspired by superman the two characters
have very similar power sets the century
possesses super strength speed
durability and of course
he can fly he also has some abilities
that superman does not have
such as invisibility phasing through
solid objects telekinesis telepathy size
and shape alteration and he can heal
himself and others and even resurrects
the dead the explanation for most of
these powers however
is that the sentry is able to manipulate
matter at a molecular level which allows
him to do basically anything he wants to
the century's skill at matter
manipulation is so prodigious that he
was able to manipulate the molecules
within the molecule man owen reese who
himself is an extremely adept matter
manipulator something that i do want to
point out here though
is that when that happened with the
molecule man one of the things people
tend to forget to bring up is that the
molecule man
was much weaker than he was back during
the days of like secret wars 2.
he was ridiculously powerful during
secret wars 2. he was a multiversal
threat by the time this came around with
the century his power had been decreased
by a
massive scale he was like a franklin
richards level character now that
changed when hickman wrote avengers in
new avengers and beefed his power
back up but at the moment or at least at
the time this story was written he was a
pretty weak character now in terms of
physical strength the century is one of
the strongest
non-cosmic characters in marvel comics
and was able to battle the incredible
hulk's second strongest form the world
breaker hulk
form to an absolute standstill it's also
rumored according to peter parker that
the sentry battled galactus to a
stalemate and while we don't actually
see this happen on panel
it is mentioned in the official handbook
of the marvel universe which i don't
really like to use as a reference so i
think that we can
kind of accept it as canon if we want to
that being said anyone that's able to go
toe-to-toe with a nigh
omnipotent cosmic entity like galactus
is a force to be reckoned with the
sentry
can also harness vast amounts of energy
and when he battled another extremely
powerful entity genus vel he released
enough energy in one of his attacks
to level an entire planet not only is
the century incredibly durable virtually
to the point of invulnerability but he
also possesses advanced healing
abilities that allow him to recover from
being partly destroyed and was unable to
destroy himself
even when he attempted to do so by
flying into the heart of a sun
in one of century's most recent
appearances in annihilation scourge
vader build number one the sentry is
able to rip a hole in reality by tearing
through the barrier that separates the
negative zone from the marvel universe
which will sound pretty familiar if you
know anything about superboy prime but
if you don't just stay tuned
and we'll cover it in a few minutes but
when dealing with the sentry the
possibility of dealing with the void
must also be considered as more often
than not
the dark side of robert reynolds finds a
way to manifest itself
sooner or later now the void is every
bit as strong as the sentry if not more
powerful
and also possesses other abilities such
as shape-shifting weather manipulation
and tendrils that probe and infect the
minds of others
forcing them to see all these horrible
things from their past or their future
and so he's basically like an evil
counterpart to the century that's
powerful enough that the century is
willing to give up and forget about his
life as a superhero to eliminate the
threat he posed something kind of cool
here is during the events
of what if siege it was the the siege
what if story the siege on asgard story
and the void ended up manifesting
and then ended up like traveling out
into the universe and presumably
killing all the cosmic entities out
there right so like wiping out all life
across the universe is kind of nuts but
on the other side of this battle we have
one of the most powerful versions of
superman
superboy prime now superboy prime was
created by elliot s magan and kurt swann
and first appeared in dc comics presents
number 87 in 1985
but it wasn't until much later in 2006's
infinite crisis that he would begin
using the name superboy prime and so
this guy
is actually the kal-el from earth prime
which is the dc comics version of our
earth here in the real world where no
one has
any kind of superpowers and superheroes
only exist in works of fiction now like
the main continuity version of superman
this version is the last surviving
resident of the planet krypton and is
sent to earth just before the planet is
destroyed he's adopted by jerry and
naomi kent and given the name clark now
clark's powers manifest when he's 15
years old and haley's comet appears
above the earth as for his powers they
appear to be the exact
same as the main continuity superman's
with the exception of his vulnerability
to magic
since magic does not exist on earth
prime but he has the whole gamut of
powers that we all associate with
superman super strength super speed
invulnerability flight frost beth heat
vision x-ray vision the whole deal but
we come to see the superboy prime's
power level far
exceeds that of the main version of
superman it's never really explained
why this is the case but one theory
attributes his insane power level to the
time he spent
inside the paradise dimension where he
basically went insane
now this happens as his universe is
destroyed by the anti-monitor and crisis
on infinite earth and at the end of the
event
he alongside superman from earth 2 lois
lane from earth 2 and lex luthor from
earth 3
end up more or less kind of being
rewarded by sin by being sent off to
what was essentially heaven because the
expectation is they were never really
going to come back so it was kind of
like you know sending them off on a nice
kind of farewell
more or less but despite being there he
ends up getting pissed that he's been
robbed of his youth and becomes
incredibly jealous of conor kent the
superboy of the main dc continuity as
well as the fact that he feels like the
superheroes wasted the opportunity
to start over because they ended up just
kind of becoming darker versions right
it was kind of a meta commentary to be
honest by jeff johns basically looking
at the way superheroes existed after
crisis on infinite earth versus the way
they existed before
if anything i really think it's just
jeff john's kind of romanticizing
superhero comics in the 1950s and 60s
and 70s as opposed to like
anything else and the result was that
superboy prime hated the fact that most
heroes more or less kind of became
anti-heroes because
they would tote the line between good
guys and bad guys doing bad things to
achieve good goals
regardless he doesn't really have the
consciousness that causes superman to
hold back and simply just uses his
powers to their fullest extent
without any regard to the consequence
whatever the explanation super boy prime
is a ridiculously powerful character and
has shown it
on multiple occasions the most notable
example of his power is that he punches
his way through the barrier
that separates his pocket dimension from
the main dc universe
these punches destroy the barrier
between realities and send ripple
effects to various corners of the dc
universe
including the resurrection of jason todd
and merging all the various origin
stories of superman
into one continuity his punches also
alter the orbits of several planets and
even realigns the center of the universe
and so he's able to punch the berry of
reality
so hard that he literally changed
reality so yeah
pretty impressive stuff on another
occasion superboy prime
punched his way out of the phantom zone
which is a dimension designed to serve
as a prison for the most dangerous
threats in the dtc multiverse and is
thought to be inescapable and in another
instance he escapes the speed force
after being trapped there by the various
speedsters of the dc universe by
designing a suit designed to siphon off
the speed force's energy he's also said
to be faster than wally west who is
believed to be the fastest speedster in
dc comics at the time he's defeated the
combined forces of the justice society
of america the teen titans and doom
patrol
with minimal effort and was able to
defeat a green lantern of the daxomite
race a race similar in powers to
kryptonians that's wielding the ion
symbiote which greatly enhances his
power level in addition
superboy prime is virtually invulnerable
surviving the explosion of a bomb that
was powerful enough to destroy a galaxy
and so with all that in mind
who would win this battle between two of
the heaviest hitters and comic books
well honestly this is one of the hardest
matches to declare a winner in
for a couple of different reasons one
these are two ridiculously powerful
characters
and have always been depicted as being
able to basically do anything the plot
of the story dictates and so it's hard
to figure
out what their maximum power level is
because neither has notably reached it
what i mean is that at any point if
these two characters were to be used in
a storyline they could probably do even
more impressive things than we've
already seen
just because that's the way they're
usually written and so because of that
we have to look at what we've actually
seen them do which normally wouldn't be
a problem but there
are some inconsistencies in how the
sentry has been written over the years
for example we're to believe that he was
able to stalemate galactus but also
that world breaker hulk was able to
defeat him which simply just doesn't
make sense as strong as world waker hulk
is he's nowhere near the power level of
galactus and so it's hard to get a
concrete sense of the century's actual
power that of course is assuming that we
choose to believe that the sentry could
actually or did actually fight galactus
to a standstill with that being said i
know there will be a lot of you who
disagree with the eventual winner and
i'll admit
that i could see this battle going
either way because these characters are
just so similar but based on what we've
seen them do
i think superboy prime is the most
likely winner although century did rip
through the fabric of reality
it did not create the lasting effects of
reality warping that superboy primes
punches to the barrier of reality did
and although it's been said that the
sentry was able to steal make galactus
that just seems like more of an outlier
to me when we look at his other feats
which although impressive
have not been on the level of what
superboy prime has done
and so while this is a close call i
think these two would have an
epic battle regardless of who wins and i
have to give the edge here to superboy
prime but let me know what you guys
think down in the comments section i'm
sure there's going to be a lot
of disagreement a lot of debate and
that's what's so great about this
is everyone believes they're right
but with that being said guys we're
going to bring this video to an end if
you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like
if you guys want to be part of more of
these versus battles go check out
patreon you will find a link down in the
description and i will catch you all
later
peace
[Music]
you